on ne peut pas imputer à l'Europe les
déficiences de la politique énergétique
française
depuis 20 ans nous avons supprimé 13
gigawatts de capacité de production
d'électricité pilotable et on en a
recréé pratiquement on n'a pas recréé le
seul élément décisif qui est positif qui
était fait c'est le lancement de
Flamanville qui n'a toujours pas en
exploitation donc
comme vous dites un pays qui a été
pendant 20 25 ans exportateur
d'électricité se retrouve actuellement
importateur alors ça ne pèse pas très
lourd donc homosexuel parce que c'est
relativement limité mais ça nous met en
situation d'avoir tous les à-coups du
marché européen
et le marché européen il ne fonctionne
pas actuellement où il fonctionne de
manière parfaitement aberrantes
c'est-à-dire que le prix électricité
n'est pas le prix des coûts de
production d'électricité c'est le prix
du gaz
or le gaz est devenu une valeur
spéculative depuis le l'affaire
l'Ukraine donc on est monté à des
sommets extraordinaires on est
redescendu on va ça va remonter parce
que les Chinois vont redevenir
importateur de gaz donc on a un produit
parfaitement spéculatif qui est devenu
qui est le gaz qui fixe le prix de
l'électricité c'est une situation
aberrante il faut sortir de ça mais moi
je pense que d'abord à moyen terme il
faut lancer un programme de de réacteurs
nucléaires qui nous mettent en situation
c'est ce qu'il commence à faire mais
plus tard c'est 2022 ça veut dire que
c'est en 2035 que nous aurons les
premiers effets entre 2035 et 2040
parenthèse le Gallois là aux fermeture
de Fessenheim c'est une opération
c'est un cadeau qui a été fait
certainement
aux écologistes qui étaient à ce
moment-là au gouvernement
ou peut-être la pression allemande qui
est quand même demander de faire le la
fermeture de Fessenheim je reviens sur
le marché de l'électricité
il faut trouver une solution à ce marché
vous dites la solution à moyen terme
c'est la reconstruction de de la
construction de nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires comme vous dites c'est loin à
court terme comment on fait à court
terme il y a pas de solution autre
peut-être que de créer des capacités au
gaz tout ça ça se fait rapidement ce qui
est quand même
paradoxal puisque c'est une énergie
fossile même si elle met moins de CO2
que le charbon ça reste une énergie
fossile qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
justement dans la capacité au gaz c'est
central de gaz le centre le problème
c'est que ça nous fait de plus en plus
dépendant du gaz et donc ça nous fait
c'est pour la souveraineté c'est quand
même on a le choix entre les Algériens
et les Russes c'est c'est un problème
que que qui résulte je vous le dis de 20
ans de politique énergétiques confiait à
un ministère que le ministère de
l'Environnement qui ne peut qui ne voit
qu'un seul axe cela et je pense que si
on ne peut pas réformer le marché du
l'électricité il va falloir sortir
moi je regarde tous les jours les prix
l'électricité les les espagnols et
portugais sont sortis du marché
électricité il paye l'électricité il
paye l'électricité beaucoup moins cher
que nous je me dis et si l'électric
qu'est-ce qu'on risque à sortir de ce
l'argument avancé c'est que on
désorganise complètement le marché des
autres puisque la France est en
interconnexion avec tous ses voisins
j'entends cet argument ce que je sais
c'est que avant le marché unique
d'électricité on s'est changé
l'électricité il y avait une bourse qui
se trouve en Suisse une chambre de
compensation il y avait des appels
d'offres et on a porté l'électricité en
choisissant le fournisseur le le le plus
compétitif
je me dis qu'on peut maintenir les
intérêts connexions et ne pas avoir ce
système de marché unique fondé sur le
coût marginal de la dernière unité
produisons
le gaz
[Musique]